do you ever get into character and stay
in character on the set like you know
like the guy who played Lincoln and he's
got to walk and you gotta call him
Lincoln off to say no you don't do any
of that no no you're an actor yeah yeah
home I know what I'm gonna do when I get
to work it's easy you know you don't
shoot more than two and a half pages a
day yeah a piece of cake you know you
don't have to learn anything from
beginning to end you know I know all the
lines I know everybody's lines I know
all this stuff is that what you do I
have fun when Quentin hands you a script
because we're talking about uh hateful
late today but when he specifically
hands you a script those scripts are
dense right this guy loves dialogue yes
not too many uh directors even do that
that's probably why you always want to
be in his films right because it gives
you something to do well you you explain
yourself yeah to the audience to other
people right you're a completely formed
character you have relationships with
people that are in the script and what
do you do to prepare for fun he has
rehearsal but do you do you in order you
learn the whole script right away is
that your thing no I sit at home I read
it I read it maybe four or five times
then I go back into it uh and
create a biography for myself from info
that's in the script and things that I'm
able to make up about that character
because of his relationships with other
people or what he says about himself so
the key to good acting if I if I may is
that you sit at home you read the script
you read about the character and then
you create a whole life for that
character till you understand who he is
I do yeah and then when you get on set
you're you're suddenly that guy anyway
because you feel like you have a lot of
stuff to to bring with you maybe you
know where where he's coming from what
he was doing before he got to this
situation where he's going when he
leaves that situation what kind of food
he might want to eat while he's there or
it's not specific out there it can be
yeah do you ever uh do you do you ever
pull from someone like do you ever in a
sense do an impression like if someone
in your past life you know someone from
you know maybe from childhood and say oh
I'll use that guy's kind of accent I'll
use it it's all the term yeah that's how
it's done right yeah you change your
wall because you like somebody's
character walk I remember my I uh
hairdresser Robert
's sister had this uh red hair that was
kind of naughty and when I saw it I I
told him take a picture of your sister's
hair because I want to use that in the
movie one day and then I ended up using
it in negotiator wow yeah these little
things are what make you human as a
character you could bring these guys
that's that's why I love you know riding
the subway I still ride Subway when I'm
here because I like looking at people
and I ride around in cars when I'm in
other cities and check out the the area
or or or the the kind of culture that's
different from where I am who's the guy
that you loved acting with so much that
made it easy for you to really get into
character there's been a few who
um Bobby is awesome De Niro when we did
Jackie Brown he's the real deal
incredible yeah
um
why why is he so good like it's just
that he you just believe who he is he
commits yeah you commit to the moment to
the character you know and he's there